all right
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
this conference is being recorded
whenever you're ready amanda
all right if we are good to go then we
will get started thank you so much to
everyone for joining us today my name is
that informs the ongoing response and
planning for longer term management of
covet 19 in canada
since the last update multiple
indicators show that canada is past the
peak of the omicron wave though
infection rates remain elevated and
hospitals are heavily strained
in the presence of overall high
vaccination rates health authorities are
closely monitoring improvements of these
epidemiological indicators in order to
guide the step-wise easing of measures
for the immediate future key preventive
measures remain important for relieving
the accumulated pressure on hospitals
some measures will also be important for
protecting vulnerable populations and
maintaining readiness for a possible
resurgence
this includes reducing vaccination
coverage gaps and encouraging the use of
personal protective practices such as
avoiding crowding opting for well
ventilated spaces and wearing masks as
appropriate
though we are hopeful we are approaching
a period of reduced transmission
allowing canadians a chance to regain a
sense of normalcy we know that sasko v2
virus is not going away
to that end we must also use this time
to prepare for the longer term by
maintaining a cohesive approach across
the country strengthening capacity for
rapid detection and response and using
personal practices as and where needed
to better protect ourselves and each
other
foreign
result
slide one
since the last epidemiology and modeling
update in january
multiple indicators of cova-19 disease
spread including lab test positivity
rt or effective reproduction number
wastewater surveillance trends and daily
reported cases indicate that canada is
past the peak of the omicron wave
nationally
although testing continues to
underestimate true infections many
jurisdictions across canada are now
reporting weekly declines in the average
number of reported cases
as of february the 16th the latest
national seven-day average was over 8
100 new cases being reported daily which
was a 27 percent decrease compared to
the week prior
dear positive due
so that while there is a drop in the
number of tests being conducted
percent positivity continues to decline
which aligns with multiple other data
sources indicating reduced levels of
infection
slide 3
community-based wastewater surveillance
also provides a way to estimate the true
number and trend of infections during
this period of reduced general
population testing
the black line shows the number of
actual reported cases from traditional
case-based surveillance in five canadian
cities
while the blue line shows the estimated
number of true cases based on
community-based covariating wastewater
signals in those same cities
this method which aligns with other data
sources indicates that the trend and
peak of the omicron wave involves a much
higher number of cases than were
detected through case-based surveillance
notably the estimated blue line
trajectory does not take into account
the easing of public health measures
which could result in some bumps over
the coming weeks
dear positive cat the town dance slide
four
hospitalization trends are shown for
canada's six most populous provinces
while recognizing that omicron has been
widespread
impacting hospital capacity across the
country
despite a lower risk of hospitalization
and even lower risk of icu admission
associated with omicron compared to
delta
even the smaller proportion of cases
that resulted in hospital and critical
care admissions has been substantial
together
the unprecedented volume of cases over a
short time period and increased
self-illness
and isolation requirements have had a
heavy impact
fortunately
we are seeing continued hopeful signs of
slowing trends in hospitalization
and critical care
over the past two weeks
many jurisdictions
reported
weekly reductions in the daily number of
people with covet 19 being treated in
hospitals
these declines are most evident in
ontario and quebec which were the first
to experience the omicron search
and now appear
to be past the peak
of hospital and critical care impact
compared to last week's update the
latest data are showing a sixteen
percent decrease in the number of people
with covid19 being treated in hospitals
daily
however
that is still a seven day average of
over eight thousand one 100 in hospitals
each day including
900 in intensive care and 95 debts were
reported daily relieving the pressure on
hospitals is a key priority as we
cautiously come out of the omicron wave
to recover as well as strengthen our
capacity and resilience to manage
sas
covey to virus over the longer term
sly five
it is important to note that based on
selected hospitals data for the month of
january
40 percent of patients were admitted due
to their covert 90 infection while the
remainder were emitted for other reasons
while the overall volume of omicron
cases drove up hospitalization rates
across all age groups the age
distribution of cases in hospital is
similar to previous waves of the
pandemic with hospitalization rates
highest among older canadians
over the past month severe outcomes
including the number of hospital and icu
admissions and deaths were highest
amongst adults 60 years of age and older
cases in infants age under one year are
almost six times more likely to be
hospitalized than children aged one to
four years
but while hospitalization numbers have
increased in this age group compared to
previous waves they remain low overall
likewise children continue to have low
rates of intensive care missions overall
however infants age under one year have
the highest rates which over the past
month have been higher
than at any other time previously during
the pandemic
this is why it is particularly important
for parents and close contacts of
infants and young children to continue
taking measures to reduce the risk of
exposure among children
dear positive cis
slide six
canadians aged 12 years or older
have 88 or higher vaccine coverage with
at least two doses
and coverage is still increasing among
five to 11 year olds
who
more recently became eligible for
vaccination as of february 13th
56 percent have at least one dose
all told there are currently more than
5.6 million canadians who are eligible
but are not yet vaccinated or have less
than two doses of coven-19 vaccines
this week
health canada approved the nova works
nova soviet vaccine which is the first
covin-19 recombinant protein
subunit vaccine to be authorized for use
in adults in canada
novak soviet vaccine uses a protein
based vaccine technology which has been
in use in canada and around the world
for many years for prevention of other
vaccine-preventable diseases such as
petroleum and hepatitis b
among the more than 2.5 million canadian
adults aged 18 years or older who have
not yet been vaccinated against covid19
novak soviet vaccine provides an option
for those who cannot or do not want to
receive an mrna vaccine
as well many canadians have completed
their primary series with at least two
doses need a booster dose to restore
immunity that may have waned over time
and to provide better protection against
the omicron variant
given substantially higher risk of
hospitalizations and critical illness
with increasing age
improving booster dose coverage
particularly among adults aged 50 years
or older is particularly important
dear positive bit
slide 8
since vaccines became available
hospitalization rates have been
consistently lower
among fully vaccinated people
compared to unvaccinated people
this protective advantage has varied but
remained substantial
across pandemic waves
clearly demonstrating that
having two or more doses is highly
protective
for the month of january
even as
omicron began to search in canada
vaccinated people
continue to be at lower risk of hospital
admission than unvaccinated people with
a hospitalization rate that was four
times lower
among fully vaccinated people than among
unvaccinated people and
13 times lower among fully vaccinated
people with an additional dose
than
among
unvaccinated people in general
protection against hospitalization
is approximately 90 percent or more soon
after
an
mrna kobe 19 vaccine booster which is
about 10 to 20 percent higher than
shortly after the second dose
slide
this updated longer range forecast
showing estimated daily cases on the
left and daily hospital emissions on the
right illustrates how the omicron wave
could evolve in the coming weeks with
many jurisdictions easing public health
measures
note due to changes in data availability
there is significant uncertainty in
these forecasts
the three scenarios shown in each figure
show that while omicron activity has
likely peaked easing of public health
measures could still lead to resurgence
the blue line trajectory show that with
a moderate effect of easing public
health measures
we could expect a limited resurgence of
daily cases with potential for a more
modest resurgence in daily hospital
emissions towards the spring
the red line trajectory shows that with
a more substantial effect of easing
measures we could expect a larger
resurgence of daily omicron cases
potentially exceeding prior peaks but
similarly the peak of daily hospital
emissions could be much lower
while resurgence of cases is not
unexpected
given the characteristics of the omicron
variant the good news is that current
levels of immunity in the canadian
population are expected to reduce the
impact of the omicron infections going
forward in particular with an increasing
proportion of breakthrough infections in
people with some prior immunity from
vaccination and or infection it is
expected that a smaller proportion will
require hospital emission
such that the impact on our healthcare
system could be less severe even with a
large number of cases
dear positive this
is like 10.
virus has been continually evolving
since its emergence in the late 2019
resulting in the occurrence and
accumulation of random mutations that
can impact virus characteristics
such as transmissibility and severity
some of these mutations have helped the
virus spread more easily
including by evading immune protection
as it passes from person to person
in this way accumulated mutations can
result in new variants of concern
which may emerge
from existing variants
or new variants such as omicron can also
appear more suddenly
if accumulating mutations stay hidden
from our surveillance for example if the
virus evolves in an immunocompromised
person
or an animal host
this highlights why we need to monitor
and be prepared for emergence of new
variants that could appear suddenly
slide 11
almost all countries around the world
have reported the omicron variant
although some are further ahead than
others in coming through the omicron
wave
we are closely monitoring other
countries that have similarly passed the
omicron peak including those that have
begun to ease public health measures
having achieved a high vaccination
coverage
likewise we are monitoring the impact of
genetic sub-lineages of the omicron
variant such as the ba 0.2
while continuing to look out for the
emergence of other variants of concern
as well as transmission of sasko v2
amongst animal populations
global collaboration remains as
important as ever including
strengthening surveillance and research
and ensuring access to vaccinations and
treatments
dear positive dues
slide 12
together the latest model scenarios show
that while we need to continue a
cautious approach to easing measures and
closely monitor severity indicators
there is room for optimism
thanks to the sacrifices and enduring
strength of canadians
we are in a stronger position than ever
before
vaccination together with public health
measures and changes we have made to our
daily routine routines have worked to
minimize cov19
serious harms and
safe lives
although resurgence is still possible
canada's stronger foundation of
protection
gained through the development and
application of a range of tools can help
us achieve a more balanced and
sustainable approach for long-term
management of copy 19. as we transition
out of the
crisis phase we can continue to rely on
the crucial tools for prevention early
detection and response
as we get out of the crisis phase we can
continue to rely on the crucial tools
for prevention early detection and
response
including vaccines testing robust
surveillance treatments and public
health and healthcare infrastructures
for public health and individuals alike
maintaining caution and instead of
readiness
will be our strongest advantage
as we recover and enhance our search
capacity
for future response
for individuals and families
this includes keeping covey 19
vaccinations up to date
including getting a boosted dose when
eligible
being aware of evolving risks
and maintaining individual protective
practices
such as wearing masks staying home when
sick and improving
ventilation of indoor spaces
thank
to all canadians for their ongoing
efforts
thanks as a sacrifices enduring strength
of canadians we are in a stronger
position than ever before
vaccination together with public health
measures and changes we have made to our
daily routines have worked to minimize
cover 19 serious harms and save lives
although resurgence is still possible
canada's strong and stronger foundation
of protection gained through the
development and application of a range
of tools can help us achieve a more
balanced and sustainable approach
as we strive to reduce serious outcomes
these tools can help support vulnerable
populations and reduce impacts on health
systems while minimizing societal
disruption
as we transition out of the crisis phase
we can continue to rely on crucial tools
for prevention early detection and
response including vaccines testing
robust surveillance treatments and
public health and healthcare
infrastructure
for public health and individuals alike
maintaining caution and a state of
readiness will be our strongest
advantage as we recover and enhance our
surge capacity for future response
for individuals and families this
includes keeping overnighting
vaccinations up to date including
getting a boosted dose when eligible
being aware of evolving risks and
maintaining individual protective
practices such as wearing masks staying
home when sick and improving ventilation
of
indoor spaces
for ongoing efforts of countless
canadians thank you
max c
megridge
great
thank you very much uh i believe that
concludes the presentation from our
guests today so we will start with the
question period it'll be one question
one follow-up as a reminder
question with the question period one
question one follow up
and i will just unmute let's see here
sorry about this
hello can you hear
me thank you thank you yes
happy friday to everyone um so nasty the
nasty document released yesterday says
novovax is good for appealing to vaccine
hesitant folks so are you aware of any
government plans to use it for that
purposes
for that purpose for canadians and if so
can you explain how this will be done
yes so we're in um
close contact with province and
territories and they are the ones who
are going to be telling us how much of
the vaccine they need based on their
understanding of their population's
requirements
on the whole i think people are looking
at well what's the proportion of the
population that hasn't got a booster
even though um they
already had two doses that that's one
statistic but then of course there are
some canadians who have
never really even got their first dose
so these are the sort of baseline
statistics that provinces will have
and then there are um surveys and public
opinion research
looking at well what's the proportion of
individuals who have not yet got a
vaccine who may want an alternative
vaccine
and these vary i think across the
country but some anywhere between 10 to
50 percent of those those who have not
yet been vaccinated said they would be
interested in an alternative vaccine
and so the novavax vaccine offers them
that potential option
it's dr new and i would just uh
underscore the point that i think in
canada we're so fortunate to have such a
a selection of choice of vaccines now
obviously with the
uh approval of the novovax vaccine and i
think i think canadians really need to
understand and recognize and appreciate
the fact that we have that choice and
and as dr tam said uh you know if there
are those individuals that haven't
gotten their you know first or second
dosa because of uh uh some hesitation or
or questions about the mrna vaccines
which still obviously with the hundreds
of millions of doses of a vaccine
minister around the world with uh with a
good good obviously uh effectiveness i
think is still uh still a very good
choice but now we have an additional
choice so i think canadians can can feel
very good about the fact that you know
they have this choice and i think really
it underscores the importance of going
forward and getting vaccinated
and in terms of actually sorry in terms
of actually reaching out
to these folks like what do you
recommend is the best way to reach them
are we talking advertising campaigns
yes the actual operationalization
of the vaccine uh programs are done by
provinces and local jurisdictions but i
think it would be more of a multifaceted
approach has never been a
one-size-fits-all for every population
but certainly outreach more broadly like
we're doing now and and public
announcements uh but also at a more
local level in terms of the
understanding of which populations might
still need um and a different vaccine
some individuals of course have some
contraindication based on maybe a a
reaction that is severe that's been
assessed um
post mrna vaccine so those individuals
would consult with the physicians
on the risk and benefits of receiving
different vaccines and so outreach to
health care providers
making sure they know that
this vaccine is an option for their
patients is another domain and they're
in the best position to explain the
relative risks and benefits of the
options in front of an individual so i
think it'll be multifaceted
approach
and i can't tell you how what channels
uh the vaccines are going to be
provided in because that's in the local
setting but we do know that this vaccine
is fridge stable which also makes it
easier logistically
to distribute
thank you okay our next question will be
from sebastian de rosier
radio canada
thank you
for taking my question
first of all
i would like to ask what do you think
about restrictions at the border travel
restrictions that were announced this
week
by minister diclo
more specifically
why is it always necessary to show a lab
antigen test
when will those restrictions be lifted
answer doctor no here i could start
thank you for your question
it's all about analyzing
scientific
evidence at the border and to also look
at the epidemiological data of what is
happening in the country compared to
other foreign countries
what we are seeing are the borders
the test committee molecular with the
requirement of a molecular test and now
a rapid antigen test
we are seeing a certain percentage of
travelers coming to our borders testing
positive for cov19
it's less so for vaccinated people
compared to unvaccinated people
there's still a percentage
so i think it's something to monitor
because we know that ultimately
maybe in the future
it's going to we will have to be looking
at the tolerance threshold and risk
management because when you look at what
is happening in canada compared to other
countries we need to find a balance
but now it's
a problem
we are continuing to analyze scientific
data
maybe next week
with the data that we recently received
during the week ending 12th of february
about two percent
of totally vaccinated people
are still testing positive and that is
thanks to the requirement
of testing before they get to canada and
amongst the unvaccinated people
or partially vaccinated people the
positivity rate
is
5.46 so it's something to monitor
the risk is not zero it's never zero but
something to monitor
it's less than before
because before the positivity rate was
higher but now
with the omicron wave it reduced so i
think that we've found ourselves in
another position we're looking at the
scientific data
and we may change the policy as time
goes by question the percentages you are
giving are for travelers who get to the
border yes
very well my second question
concerns the third
dose the booster dose the quebec
government is today announcing that
young people between 12 and 17
will be eligible
for this booster dose from tomorrow
this wasn't the case before
what do you think about this are you in
favor
of the administration of the booster
dose for minors answer
we are seeing what is happening with
vaccine coverage in canada
generally speaking
canada did well when you look at the
vaccination rate
for people who received
the first two
doses the rate is good
i think we have also seen
that when we look at the general
population there is a drop
in immunity protection after some months
after about six months we have also seen
that with a booster dose
a third dose
against various variants including
omicron can increase
so
i think it's because of it's because of
science that the government of quebec
and other governments throughout the
country
are beginning to offer a boosted dose
to the general population for all those
who are eligible
including
teenagers
it's also important
to see that
it is recommended that for people who
have completed the primary series they
have to wait six months before they
receive the booster dose
thank you
thank you our next question will be from
dylan robertson with the winnipeg free
press
hi doctors thanks so much for taking our
questions today i wanted to ask dr tam
what your message is to manitobans
because we see the hospitalizations are
supposed to go up again but it's nowhere
near the peak that we saw last month and
almost all the restrictions are being
lifted in the province but we still have
a major backlog in care
and so that will clearly put some sort
of strain on that system
so i know you're not here to tell the
provincial government what to do but i'm
wondering what would you tell the public
in manitoba should they go above and
beyond the masking and gathering
restrictions being lifted or do you have
any kind of advice
well i think very key to this transition
period um we expect some turbulence or
bumps in the epidemic curve
is that individuals can certainly get
boosts their booster shots that they're
eligible that you've seen the gap still
in some of the uptake of vaccines
um even in people who've got the first
and second dose
so that's one thing and secondly i think
masking in indoor spaces when you're not
with your household members
that can potentially continue as a habit
as a personal protective measure going
forwards
and taking all the knowledge that you
have gained
over the last couple of years in how to
reduce risk based on your personal
circumstances because everyone's a
little bit different in terms of their
risks and who they're in contact with
but i think the message is that the
omicron virus will continue to circulate
it hasn't disappeared
and
will probably continue at quite a high
level
for a number of weeks and we're
monitoring that very closely right now
and so individuals can take those
additional measures
based on their
personal contacts i have to also say
that we are presenting national level
data and some of it may be broken down
provincially but they're actually quite
different virus activities within the
provinces
themselves so there are some northern
areas that actually still experiencing
quite high activities compared to maybe
some of them uh bigger cities
and so that should be taken into account
as well
thanks so much and as a follow-up i just
wanted to get your thoughts on the
modeling itself because we know this is
not a crystal ball that there's a lot of
changes but a month ago the projection
had manitoba bound for around 180
hospitalizations a day the peak ended up
being less than half of that so i'm not
trying to criticize i think we know that
these modelings all have lots of caveats
but could you perhaps walk me through
what factors might have shaped that
different outcome in manitoba
yes so the
modeling shows what could happen
but what actually makes a difference and
i always like to change
love to see actual data if it's properly
collected to be better than the
projections because that shows that the
measures are working or people are
you know the the measures themselves
that there could be more measures or
more people taking out vaccines or other
factors
that have uh provided a more optimistic
trajectory the other aspects um include
um you know there's lot
the models uh don't incorporate every
single dynamic that is happening with
immunity in the population
it's also possible that you know quite a
lot of infections occurred
which provides more um
protection for population as well
and the models also doesn't take into
account waning immunity so they're not
there to um to to cover all bases
but uh i
always think that it's great to be
proven
as
you know not
to have a
real life experience that is better than
the projected forecast
uh that shows that people have um
really taken to heart some of the public
health advice
okay our next question will be from
raymond fillion de teveaux
i'd like to ask a question about the
graph on page nine when we look at the
red curve to the right
should we take it that the easing of
measures
could lead to a resurgence and
hospitalizations
as serious as what we saw at the
beginning of the year
it's always possible
with easing of public health measures
for us to see a resurgence of infections
another important thing is that we all
the tools we have
we know that uh infection cases
of what we see in in
the desert indicator
or rather they could be it's not like as
if there will be other indicators
we are seeing that with umicron
the serious illnesses and some people
who need to be in icus it's less than
before
yes it's i believe that all governments
throughout the country
are closely
monitoring
with the easing of public health
measures in their administrations and
jurisdictions it's something to be
monitored we need to find out what the
impact will be on public health systems
and
similarly to
severe
illnesses
we need to separate cases of infection
and also look at what will happen
with the impact on the public health
systems
question when we look at what is
happening
in
in denmark there was an explosion of
cases and deaths from what i saw at the
beginning of the week
are you at ease with what was announced
in ontario and quebec over the past few
days when it comes to the easing of
measures coming up in the next few weeks
doctor new here answer it's not
up to me
to
to rule or to say anything on what the
government of quebec
did
together with all the public health
authorities we are all on the same page
who've been able to ride the omicron
wave
so now
the provinces and territories are
trading carefully
and easing public health
restrictions
we have to rely on experiences from
other countries and as you said
particularly some countries in europe
because sometimes they're ahead of us
so we shall learn from their experiences
the same thing with quebec and ontario
maybe
they
are ahead with the omicron
maybe they went through the peak before
the other provinces and jurisdictions
it's something to monitor
of course we need to find a balance
because i think that
everyone wants
to go back to
some sort of normalcy
of society
as before
but at the same time we need to protect
our health care system
that is the balance that all provinces
and territories are trying to find
it's something so monitor in the weeks
ahead
okay thank you our next question will be
from frederick lacroix
please go ahead
we have seen that in some provinces like
quebec and ontario they have announced
the removal of the vaccine passport in
the next few weeks in your opinion is
this a measure that should have been
kept
on is it too early to withdraw the
vaccine passport we know the impact that
this vaccine passport had on vaccination
and the transmission of the virus
answer thank you for the question dr no
here let me start
it's interesting you are talking about
the vaccine passport i believe dr tam
and myself
observed before
that from what we saw from evidence
when a government makes an announcement
about the requirement for the vaccine
passport
the vaccine rate
increases
a bit
it's true that that motivated some
people to get vaccinated but it's
interesting for me
to go back to public health principles
we know it's very important to increase
vaccine coverage as much as possible
because
relying on evidence we know that
vaccines are
effective and efficient and they provide
good protection to the vaccinated people
that is a certainty
and every scientist agrees on that
but maybe
it's a personal perspective now but i
think it's also it's something that's
very important
besides a quantitative science with the
figures and the data
and hospitalization rates
we now know that
we must properly understand
behavioral sciences or quantitative
sciences qualitative sciences because
all that is important
encourage people to get vaccinated so we
can increase vaccine coverage
of course various governments used
means like vaccine
the vaccine passport but it's not only
about using the vaccine passport
ultimately it's very important
to find out
what
is motivating people
how are sub populations
behaving
maybe people who have not yet been
vaccinated so far so we need to find out
how to find ways of increasing vaccine
coverage
it's not only about asking people to get
vaccinated or using the vaccine passport
question
is it too early to to withdraw the
vaccine passport
answer that's a decision that is up to
the provincial and territorial
government
i've said on several occasions that
if we want to
increase vaccine coverage it's always
better
well we've seen that many canadians
rely on science
and we provide information
that gives the benefits and
disadvantages of vaccines and we see
that the vaccine coverage is very high
in general amongst canadians
if the provincial and territorial
governments
also want to use other means of
increasing vaccine coverage
it's a decision that is up to them
it's not for me
to to to say what they have to do but
it's something we need to monitor in the
coming weeks we need to see what is
going to happen looking at the
epidemiology
question thank you looking back to the
three scenarios you
presented before
is there one that is more likely than
the other looking at the
easing measures that we are not the
easing of measures as announced
answer
on several locations we've said that we
do not have the crystal wall canada is a
vast country
we have seen
that the reality
on the field in each province and
territory is different
what is happening in ontario and quebec
may be different from what is happening
in other territories looking at their
context population and epidemiology i
think each province and territory
may have to adopt a different approach
in easing public health measures
they may vary from one part of the
country to another
for me it's very difficult
to tell you now
which scenario is the most
probable it's something to monitor
at the country as a whole it's difficult
with the most populous countries like
quebec and ontario
what happens in such provinces
may have an impact
on what happens
in the rest of the country but each
province and territory is faced with
different realities thank you
thank you and i don't see any further
hands raised so i'm gonna just take this
chance to ask uh one question on behalf
of one of my global news colleagues uh
reminder for anyone who has not asked a
question yet if you want to do so please
raise your hand and i will try to get to
you uh quickly here
this question is for dr tam dr tam
in your presentation you mentioned that
canada is transitioning out of the
crisis phase uh can you clarify what
exactly that means or are we moving out
of the worst of the omicron wave or out
of the worst of the pandemic do you
believe in general at this point
yes i think in discussion with my
colleagues the chief public health
officers we actually put a collective
statement at the beginning of the week
uh i i think we're speaking on both
counts so coming out of the omicron way
but also in the
more than two years
of experience with this pandemic is that
there's a significant buildup of
immunity in the population
and
we have more tools
we have
many many canadians having been
vaccinated
and we could do with a bit more boosting
of the boosters but
many people have rolled up their arms
and we've got treatments now coming on
board
we should be able to manage
the pandemic going into the future
without i think some of the
more stringent or restrictive public
health measures
they may still be needed if
there was a very severe variant that
escapes back to immunity for example so
we we we don't want to
completely
reduce
all of our capacities
we want to be able to surge as needed
but for now i think
given the projections
if
we don't get another variance that is
very significant in terms of impacts
we should see a
diminution of the omicron wave
and be able to
return back to some of that normalcy so
i think the idea is not to do that sort
of yo-yo effect you know for the last
couple of years where restrictions have
to come on and then they come off and
then another resurgence occurs in a way
that
overwhelms our hospitals
and so
i think
and in response to some of the previous
questions about the modeling as well is
that the key focus right now are
severity indicators like
hospitalizations
the cases might go up
but as long as that wave of
hospitalizations
is not as high then we can probably cope
with that
and
with that comes a better balance
to have some of the other social
economic activities
coming back to
more normal
approaches
and you know i think i would divide the
next period of time into different uh
time groupings if you like so right now
is a transition phase
we're trying to ease out of the omicron
wave we're trying to take the public
into a different space
from um
increasing their abilities to manage
their own risks and protect themselves
while protecting the vulnerable as well
we might you know i think i need to
remind everyone there are some groups in
our population
that are at high risk still of the
covet 19 virus and we need to
collectively help support them
and um but then moving into a phase of
readiness readiness for the next wave
but really readiness for the next four
so we have our eye on the to the medium
term
of preparing for potential
uh re
resurgence but on top of other
respiratory viruses
in the coming for winter season
and then even longer term uh the
sustained uh approach to pandemic
preparedness
but reinforcing our longer-term
vaccination programs should that be
necessary for the omicron virus
for the covet 19
sasko v2 virus itself
and other platforms and infrastructures
that we need to be sustained and
enhanced
so i think we're all looking just
slightly beyond the immediate
day-to-day management of the response
into recovery and planning and readiness
excellent thank you very much i don't
see any further hands raised so i
believe that that concludes our press
conference at this point dr tam dr new
thank you so much thank you as well to
all of our interpreters for their hard
work here and have a great afternoon
everyone
you